you don't have competitors in your
industry that you need to beat right
it's a f it's a false uh narrative this
is the magical thing about business it's
an infinite game and multiple companies
selling about the same product about the
same price about the same quality can
both be wildly successful at the same
time um and to view the other players in
your category to view the other players
in your industry as worthy Rivals that
some of them do one or many things
better than you and you can learn from
them but the only true competitor is
yourself how do you do better than
yourself how do you make your leaders
better this year than they were last
year how do you make your customer
service better this year than you were
than they were last year how do you make
the your Innovation and your and your
and your online tools better this year
than they were last year and learn from
everybody else but compete against
yourself first and this is the single
best long-term strategy that you can
ever deploy and you will find yourself
way more Innovative because you're not
trying to me to or catch up with
whatever you know everybody else is
doing you're thinking for yourselves and
I'll give you one example to to drive
home the point which is Microsoft versus
Apple Steve Balmer at when he was the
CEO of Microsoft was hellbent on beating
apple and their iPod and he was going to
come up with his own product and he was
going to outperform and and beat Apple
literally he talked about it obsessively
right except Apple was ignoring
Microsoft and they were trying to
compete against themselves so at some
point it's true Microsoft's product M
Microsoft's MP3 player the zoon actually
did get better than the iPod except
about a year or two later Apple
introduced the iPhone
that rendered both the iPod and the zoo
that completely obsolete Microsoft was
competing against apple apple was
competing against itself Apple was the
Innovative company